blake shelton and gwen stefani may have
been the bride and groom
but their wedding day was all about the
kids
and right in front of you guys please on
wednesday gwen shared a new shot from
the special day
this one has her in blake posing with
her three sons
kingston zuma and apollo so i think my
cool
my cool points are going up a little bit
with the kids and mom
definitely approved of the kids tuxedos
she captioned the pic thank you susie
perry for making all my boys wedding
suits we love you it's a lot of boys and
they have a lot of energy
and we have so much fun and we know gwen
made sure the entire celebration paid
tribute to her sons
who she shares with ex-husband gavin
rossdale
because i never ever thought of myself
as a career kind of person
i just wanted to be a mom for the
bride's first of two custom-made dresses
by vera wang
the boys names were embroidered into her
floor-length fail
which also sported two white roses and
the names of the bride and groom
you know she's never not been
supportive or a cheerleader just the
most encouraging
person i've ever had in my life gwen
changed into a mini dress for the
reception
which featured a pair of lovebirds
symbolizing the couple
and it was accompanied by three baby
lovebirds
representing her three sons my god who
wouldn't want to be married to win
stefani
on tuesday a source told blake and
gwen's special day was a fairytale
experience for everyone
we are just having the time of our lives
and we never expected that this late in
our lives so
we're just trying to savor every every
moment together the source added quote
everyone who attended the ceremony was
talking about gwen and blake's love for
one another
they've been so careful because they've
had their hearts broken and this wedding
made everyone feel like dreams do really
come true
they've both been through a lot and
deserve to find each other
they were meant to be a couple in every
way in addition the location of the
wedding held significance for blake and
the three boys
but my kids are really lucky as the
country star told e.t
he spent quality time with gwen's entire
family at the oklahoma estate
it's been it's been great and it's uh
it's been
a lot of fun for me to
to be the one to get to expose them to
this out in the country basically you
know
and they they love it so much her entire
family and i say her family i mean
all i'm talking about the kids the mom
the dad the brother
uh you know it's just you know there's
times when we've had
like holiday gatherings and i'm talking
about 30
plus family members from from here from
her side from my side
it's uh it's we have so much fun i don't
think he should be able
to to have that much fun it's probably
not legal in california